it's no secret that xbox game pass is
one of the best deals in gaming
offering a rotating catalog of old
favorites day one releases
and games you're kicking yourself that
you missed all for a fairly decent price
bump that price up a little to get game
pass ultimate and the catalog is
expanded even further
offering ea titles and throwing some pc
games in the mix too
with so many games on offer where do you
even begin
look no further here are some
recommendations for the best games to
play on game pass
based on what you're in the mood for for
more make sure to like this video and
subscribe
genesis noir is a trippy stylized cosmic
hard-boiled romp that'll take you
through the ripples of space and time
to solve a murder mystery that triggered
the big bang
yes you heard that correctly all of
which is packaged with a slamming beat
bop style jazz soundtrack and an
intergalactic surrealist style cranked
up so high
it's enough to make carl sagan blush and
best of all it's not too demanding of
the player either but is changing things
up just enough to keep you hooked if
you're looking to kick back with a group
of friends
then there are a lot of co-op games on
offer escape a jail with your buddy in a
way out
or band together with a group in project
winter to survive the harsh snow
and try not to get stabbed in the back
if you're like among us which
is also on game pass try that if you're
looking for something a little longer in
the tail
grab some pails and set sail in sea of
thieves
because what's more fun than being a
pirate being a pirate with a cute animal
companion
that's what if you bounced off sea of
thieves when it first launched
now's the time to head back there's a
ton of new things to do and honestly
it just makes for a really nice hub to
hang around and goof off together in
if you're not in the mood to goof off
and want something a little bit more
thought provoking then you can try your
hand at near automata careful though
it'll definitely just make you very very
contemplative about the meaning
of life it feels weird to recommend a
game that'll make you sad but
sometimes a little melancholy can spark
the soul and what remains of edith finch
is one of the most affecting games out
there you play as
peter finch as she returns to her old
family home
and explores each room and talks about
her family each family member's story is
told through
a unique vignette and is a truly
beautiful exploration of
death and grief i can't recommend edith
finch enough but i'm aware
that it might be a bit of a bummer it is
an easy 1000g though if that's your
thing
so let's pump things up a bit with
killer queen black killer queen is an
incredible
and frenetic arcade game for up to 10
players
and killer queen black lets you take
that experience home to enjoy from the
comfort
of your own couch you gotta fight for
your
hive tupac i don't know how to finish
that song but
beastie boys is a pun that works on
multiple levels you have multiple ways
to fight for your hive and it's part
action game part strategy
it may seem simple at first but it's one
of those games where you'll be screaming
at the screen
in no time if you're looking for
something a little more challenging ori
in the blind forest and its sequel
or in the will of the wisps can
definitely fill that void
don't let those beautiful visuals fool
you within is a pretty tricky platformer
if you utter the words the tree to folks
who have played
they might get a far away look in their
eye as if to tell you
not to do it but honestly it's such a
fun challenge
requiring a deft hand in a true command
of ori's abilities
honestly one of the best metroidvanias
of recent years
hey you are finally awake
time for the obligatory bethesda section
an absolutely historic acquisition in
the gaming world in early 2021
the deal was finalized and bethesda
officially joined
the xbox family and a number of its
games joined
game pass that means there are so many
to delve through from dooms to elder
scrolls
fallouts to wolfensteins but i'm here to
plead with you
please play an arcane game dishonored
dishonored to or pray any one of those
is an absolute banger of a choice
if you love stealthy immersive sims and
you haven't played the dishonored series
you're doing yourself
a huge disservice if you want to get
into some messed up sci-fi with aliens
and powers
prey is your game there's a real
artistic touch to everything arcane
makes and game pass is an amazing way to
introduce yourself
to that studio and look i'd be a bad
employee of gamespot if i didn't use
this time
to recommend that you finally play
yakuza
yakuza 0 through to 6 are all on game
pass
and i don't have enough good words to
say about that series
it's a gritty yakuza crime drama meets
surreal comedy
meets management mini games that'll take
over your life
give it a whirl and see what the fuss is
about you can go from laughing out loud
at how absurd it gets
to really getting down into your feels
in no time
at all treat yourself and play through
here used journey
[Music]
the game pass library is ever changing
so we'll be updating this list
make sure to like and subscribe for more
on game pass and
everything xbox let me know your
favorite gem you discovered on game pass
and we might highlight it in the next
vid for everyone to enjoy
i'm crutindovina and you can find me on
twitter
at curt underscore in divina see you
later folks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you